[Applaudissements]
précurseur de la dalle est plus qu 11
eme qu'ulysse reste verra chrome alors
vous pouvez me croire
aujourd'hui encore les traitements
contre le vieillissement reste assez
moyenâgeux ceci dit on va pas cracher
sur quelques potes et à des niveaux plus
je devais avoir une vingtaine d'années
comme certains d'entre vous lorsque j'ai
réalisé
nous étions en face d'une convergence
technologies qui pourraient nous
permettre de ralentir voire même
d'arrêter les mains nouées décennies à
venir et faire de nous potentiellement
la première génération des humains un
mortel alors remarquer que je dis est
mortel et pas immortel parce que le
vieillissement ou pas on pourra pas
empêcher les gens de mourir ou même de
gagner à darwin avoir hâte et s'arrête à
nos plus grands par exemple l'empereur
maximilien premier de l'amour mort en
1519 au rang d'une partie de chasse une
indigestion de mollo on voit bien
vieillissement au bar pourra pas
empêcher les moyens mais ceci dit je
trouve que l'idée de ne plus avoir de
date de péremption est plutôt séduisante
et c'est pour ça que j'ai dédié ma vie à
une chose donner le choix donné le choix
le plus vite possible à l'humanité de
pouvoir vivre ou de courrier à chaque
individu de vieillir ou de ne pas
vieillir
puis j'ai bien donner un assez longtemps
sur les bancs de l'école
j'ai dépassé
mais bon ingénieur doctorant 6 et post
doctorant en biologie
le cdh est idéal pour arrêter menée ce
mois là et c'était génial qui est
chercheur à dire qu'on a gardé une âme
d'enfant
les chercheurs ça consiste à repousser
les limites de la science ont journée
des boissons euros le bonheur
malheureusement pour moi de la ceni très
rezaï que pour atteindre ce que je
voulais faire dans la vie mais ça
servait strictement à rien rachetée dans
la recherche publique
là j'ai tout plaqué pour un même lancé
dans des ribambelles de création
d'entreprises innovantes dans le domaine
des biotechnologies
ja c'est vous dire si je crois dans mon
sujet imaginez qu'on va vivre un paquet
d'années pour balancer dix ans d'études
à l'aneth
j'étais bloquée parce que lorsque j'ai
réalisé
on pourrait peut-être créé la première
génération de mots sapiens morten plus
rien d'autre n'avait de sens tout paris
c'est insignifiant même développé à nos
iphone et pourtant jamais peur vers j'ai
toujours peur et on vous devriez
probablement dément avoir peur parce que
qui sait demain ce que l'humanité fera
du pouvoir de modifier le génome humain
qui poignant aujourd'hui à 100% que les
bénéfices seront supérieurs aux risques
parce que si on regarde ça dépendra des
décisions de nos politiques nos vaincre
en 40 ans ça dépendra des gens qui
votent pour eux ça dépend en partie nous
et je ne vous connais pas du coup ça me
fait peur
vous l avez compris j'ai quand même fait
mon choix pourquoi parce que c'est
aujourd'hui dans les laboratoires de
recherche que se décide sinon 20 30 ou
40 ans les gens pourront choisir de
vieillir ne pas y lire et j'ai décidé de
ne pas l'envoyer cette liberté alors
heureusement pour moi et pour vous aussi
parce que ce ne serait pas avant c'est
bien vite j'ai réalisé que j'étais pas
tout seul il y avait une réelle
révolution mondiale dans le domaine de
la lutte contre le vieillissement
vous êtes vous déjà demandé par exemple
pourquoi google a investi 1,5 milliard
de dollars pour je cite tuer la mort et
arrêter de l'ismans humains ou pourquoi
mark zuckerberg le fondateur de facebook
a déclaré cette année investir 3
milliards de dollars aussi mais lui pour
éradiquer toutes les maladies humaines
d'ici la fin du siècle
et surtout qu'est ce qui peut leur faire
penser que leurs investissements sont
rentables dans les décennies à venir
je vous laisse y réfléchir non pas un
peu si on regarde de près l'espérance de
livres d'humanité n'a pas vraiment bougé
au cours des 48 dernières années le
calme plat si ce n'est au cours des 150
dernières années où tout d'un coup on
s'est mis à gagner six heures
d'espérance de vie toutes les 24 heures
alors pour les fêtards hexagone la
couette comprenez bien que c'est un
week-end de gagner toutes les semaines
je saisis en parallèle il ya un truc qui
n'a pas bougé d'un iota
c'est la longévité de l'espèce humaine
c'est à dire l'âge maximum que peut
atteindre un individu on est resté
scotché à 101 ans et plus remarquable
c'est que cette date de péremption était
marquée dans les évangiles
je cite que mon esprit ne soit pas
indéfiniment et menée dans le remarqué
la petite voix de baryton quand je
prends la place que je vous fais
remarquer ce qu'il est cher sa vie ne
sera plus que de 120 ans genèse chapitre
6 verset 3 alors je peux vous dire je
n'étais pas impressionner par l'ancien
testament à toutes les pages mais là je
sais pas comment il mouline est
impressionnant et la question qui se
pose aujourd'hui c'est de savoir ce
qu'ils limitent principalement
l'espérance de vie de l'humanité et sa
longévité et honda nous voir c'est le
vieillissement
une sorte de programme génétique
d'autodestruction présent en chacun
d'entre vous bouddhisme en route aux
alentours de 20 ans et mène à une mort
certaine le centaines d'années après les
ressent un tank est d'ailleurs l'année
de 20 ans vous avez une chance sur mille
de mourir pour les sacs à main bonne ou
mauvaise nouvelle
ça vous regarde déjà sachez que c'est
principalement de celui-ci de maladies
infectieuses cet accident mais moi ce
que j'en tire c'est qu'en l'absence de
vieillissement
l'espérance de vie d'un français moyen
serait de milan et si on regarde ça
marche pareil pour tous les animaux
presque tous les animaux nous faille et
une souris ou un homme à partir d'un
certain âge aux chances de mourir dans
l'année augmente exponentiellement pour
l'homme à partir de 20 ans vos chances
de mourir dans l'année
double tous les sept ans vous pouvez me
croire ça monte vite et un enfant
c'était pour homo sapiens 1.0 on est là
pour voir que cela
d'échangés et d'ailleurs il existe sur
terre des espèces qui semble pas
vieillir du tout c'est le cas du renard
c'est qu'elle n'a pas lourd également
et d'ailleurs comment je suis ici un
surprofit c'est mon côté prosélyte
je lance un appel à toute la communauté
scientifique pour relancer les
recherches sur la palourde est tous ces
petits années pour faire en sorte de
comprendre les secrets leur longévité et
surtout leur ticket tout ce qui marche
le plat de spaghettis nerfs c'est toutes
les choses qui peuvent vous tuer et les
chances qu'elle y arrive chaque année
devenu alors je sais ça fait beaucoup
qu'est-ce qu'on peut remarquer ces
examens elle augmente tout à peu près de
la même manière avec l'otan - presque
tout
la bonne nouvelle c'est que j'ai étudié
précisément cette liste et assister un
ted avec moi n'en fait pas partie woods
et au pérou pendant les 15 prochaines
minutes quand vous êtes avec moi ou vous
êtes en sécurité
la deuxième chose qu'on peut apprendre
ce plat de spaghettis c'est qu'à partir
d'un certain âge si on éradique une
classe de maladie une ode prendra
immédiatement le relais
par exemple si on éradique et
l'intégralité des cancers dans
l'intégralité de l'humanité l'espérance
de vie de l'humanité augmenterait de 3,5
années c'est triste mais comme les et
kennedy il faut pas se laisser abattre
et si comme moi vous souhaitez augmenter
radicalement l'espérance de vie de
l'humanité
il suffit de ne pas traiter les
conséquences mais s'attaquer aux causes
alors même si vous me dire elle s'est
trouvée petit qu'à l'âge de 20 ans à
mourir d'un cancer ou d'un alzheimer
ça reste des statistiques assez
insignifiante lorsqu'on regarde toutes
ces maladies tout économiste à l'iese et
augmenté au cours du temps on se dit
qu'il ya une cause
si pâle à tous ces maladies le temps qui
passe le vieillissement est ainsi la
question qui se pose pour moi
aujourd'hui ne tourne pas autour du plat
de ce nom la question qui se pose pour
moi est de savoir si l'humanité dispose
des outils technologiques qui pourraient
nous permettre de reprogrammer ce
programme génétique d'autodestruction
dans les décennies à venir
et la bonne nouvelle c'est que la
révolution en cours dans le domaine des
biotechnologies no 2 pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de l'humanité
de sérieuses chances de pouvoir ralentir
voire même d'arrêter de vie il faut
comprendre que la médecine à avancer
plus rapidement en un siècle que pendant
toute l'histoire de l'humanité réunion
et c'est encore plus vrai dans les vingt
dernières années
aujourd'hui il est quasiment impossible
pour un médecin installé jour même dans
sa spécialité d'ailleurs pendant qu'on
est là entre nous si un jour vous avez
une maladie grave
je vous invite à choisir votre médecin
et des actes le mans comme vous
choisirez votre coiffeur si vous voulez
que ça finisse bien
je lis est le bon il rejoint nos moutons
découvrons ensemble à ce que le futur
nous réserve ses fabuleuses optelio
technologie dans la première chose à
faire lorsqu'on leur programme et un
code génétique
arrêtez de l'ismans c'est d'identifier
les gènes responsables du vieillissement
et c'est là qu'intervient le 1er août et
celui de technologie
le big data génétique la possibilité de
séquences et ses 5 milliards de lires le
génome d'individus
après bach ou le pull séquençage du
premier génome en 2003 le séquençage
d'un génome humain
son coût a été divisé par près de 3
millions aujourd'hui
on peut séquencer son génome pour moins
de 1000 euros et les millions de
personnes comme moi l'ont fait et c'est
la lecture de ces millions de jeunes
couples et une intelligence artificielle
adéquat qui nous permettra de faire le
lien entre chaque gène chaque maladie et
l'espérance de vie de chaque patient
vous allez venir connaître les gènes
c'est bien mais par contre il faut
arriver à les modifier
c'est là qu'intervient le deuxième outil
des biotechnologies les thérapies
géniques grosso modo une thérapie
génique consiste à modifier le génome
d'un patient en insérant un gène à
l'interné sans les dom
par exemple si vous avez une maladie
génétique comme la drépanocytose par
exemple une thérapie génique viendra
inactivé le gène responsable de la
drépanocytose et le remplacer par un
gène qui fonctionne le résultat à la fin
c'est que vous n'aurez plus la
drépanocytose huacana passionne les
foules
ceci dit je suis sûr que c'est vous qui
en a une par les thérapies géniques le
jour par exemple on a découvert que
j'aime de la gueule de bois
on en reparlera mais certains d'entrés
vous pourriez me dire il ya neuf ans
mais les thérapies géniques existe
depuis le début des années 80 alors oui
mais à l'époque on a là un gros problème
qu'on pouvait pas contrôler l'endroit où
on a inséré le nouveau gène dont le
génome du patient et ça en termes de
contrôle de résultat c'était
catastrophique
c'est un peu comme placer un mot hasard
dans une phrase ça peut faire sens mais
c'est un sacré coup de bol là c'est
pareil quand on place un gène au hasard
donc j'aime natation et ce domaine a
connu une véritable révolution en 2002
avec la découverte de crise par case
n'arrive qu'aux mots d'or une
technologie qui nous permet de modifier
le gène que nous voulons alan droite
nous voulons danger nomination alors de
mon point de vue chrysler cal lane en
l'état ne suffira pas à elle seule pour
boire arrêter le vieillissement mais ce
domaine avance à une vitesse faramineuse
cinq ans après il y à déjà plus de 2000
thérapie génique en cours de tests
cliniques principalement d'ailleurs pour
guérir les cancers
c'est l'un fois plus que l'on
antibiotiques encore nos tests cliniques
c'est un véritable raz-de-marée et ses
petites piques des dynamiques de la
révolution bio tech sam à une vitesse
pas possible nous disposons déjà de nos
outils qui pourraient nous permettre
dans une certaine mesure de ralentir le
dit
mais ceci dit il serait de bon ton
d'éviter de refaire les erreurs faisons
systématiquement dans le passé lorsqu'il
nous retrouvons encrasse une grande
découverte au début du 20e siècle par
exemple lors de l ai découvert la
radioactivité deux décennies auparavant
on était persuadé que cette énergie
magique poulet tout guérir et je suis
allez vous chercher quelques petites
plumes d'époque d'aller noir on a vu
sortir sur le marché des sodas
radioactifs donne une énergie infinie
comme la pile atomique ou cette fameuse
suppositoire à du maquillage mettre la
puissance masculine
je pense que le summum a été atteint
avec les gilets en laine auto chauffant
pour bébé aurait dû être un jour assure
la mode est passé mais on voit bien on
voit bien qui va être nécessaire pour
éviter ces écueils de pouvoir tester
rapidement et efficacement tous les
traitements expérimentaux contre le
vieillissement
et c'est là qu'intervient le troisième
outil issu de technologies les immenses
lors plus alors rassurez-vous papale de
cultiver des êtres miniatures sur des
petites plus bas gargamel porter pas des
schtroumpfs dans les urines circus
hésitent à reproduire le plus fidèlement
possible le fonctionnement d'un
organisme humain en faisant des cultures
cellulaires humaines sur des petites
puces microphonique comme celle ci s
donnait aussi a connu une énorme boum
avec l'a découvert il ya quelques années
bonne dizaine d'années d'ailleurs des
cellules souches pluripotentes induites
grosso modo une technologie qui nous
permet de prendre les cellules de peau
d'un patient et de les transformer en
cellules de base n'importe lequel de ses
organes foie poumon coeur cerveau et une
fois organisé intelligemment ces
cultures cellulaires humaines formées
multiprogrammes sur puce des humains sur
plus et c'est eux qui
permettront de tester rapidement
efficacement les traitements donc le
vieillissement en limitant au maximum
les tests sur cobayes humains et sur les
aliments j'ai pas pu m'empêcher vous
allez me dire c'est quand même plus
efficace et surtout plus rapide tester
un traitement expérimental sur quelqu'un
et nous regardait le résultat 70 ans
après ce sont des glissements
mais là où les humains sur plus seront
primordiaux c'est qui va probablement
falloir modifier des dizaines voire des
centaines de gènes chez ja même patiente
ont complètement arrêté son
vieillissement et celle acquise une
interruption cruciaux pour tester les
millions de combinaisons de thérapie
génique qui seront nécessaires pour
trouver la plus efficace
alors on le voit nous avons trois outils
issus des biotechnologies qui pourrait
nous permettre dans les décennies à
venir
le ralenti et voir d'arrêté agissements
le bide à la génétique pour identifier
les gènes responsables vieillissement
les thérapies géniques pour modifier le
génome du patient en conséquence et les
humains sur puce pour tester des
millions de combinaisons de thérapie
génique nécessaire pour trouver la prise
optima alors vous allez me dire pour la
plupart d'entre vous j'imagine le sujet
un peu nouveau seulement d'un peu
d'ouverture d'esprit
ceci dit je suis formel l'ouverture
d'esprit n'est pas une fracture du crâne
et donc ne fait pas partie de notre plat
de spaghettis vous pouvez vous
intéresser à ce sujet vous ne risquez
rien je pense que certains d'entre vous
ont peut être déjà en tête la réponse à
la question que nous posions au début de
cette présentation
qu'est ce qui fait que google et tant
d'entreprises de la silicon valley
investissent des milliards pour un
établissement m
et bien juste parce qu'ils pensent
qu'ils vont y arriver et qui pense que
les gens seront prêts impayés cher aurez
vous voulez le plus rapidement
s'il donnait ce choix l'humanité n'est
pas obligé d'ailleurs il n'est pas
nécessaire d'investir des milliards
d'euros il suffit de vous intéresser aux
sujets d'en parler autour de vous et à
force d'entendre parler autour d'eux les
responsables politiques comprendront que
ce sujet intéresse la population parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre
qu'aujourd'hui la quasi totalité des
budgets sont à l'eau et à traiter les
conséquences du vieillissement alzheimer
les cancers les infarctus
si nous allions ne serait ce qu'un
millième des sommes utilisées pour les
conséquences mais cette fois ci pour
traiter les causes le vieillissement
nous disposerions au niveau mondial d'un
budget de nuit illiards d'euros parra et
je suis convaincu qu'avec un tel budget
tout deviendra possible y compris me
donnait la joie de vous revoir tous ici
en pleine santé en 3 min 17
[Applaudissements]